Emma and riot everyone loves you
together in the lanai but this this is
the first time virtually were to
gangster squad and then crazy because
we've even seen me dance together before
interesting pose on me I know if you're
shirtless double-whammy
but now what happens because the
balancing didn't go to plan
in Crazy Stupid Love now oh give me the
dirty dancing list that's what I mean
yeah well we're meant to do that and
then what happened oh you don't remember
well I remember but I'd like to hear you
what listen when I was about 7 years old
when I was about 7 years old I was in
gymnastics class and I was on these
parallel bars that are about six feet
off the ground and I was standing on the
top of the bars and the teacher was
holding me by the ankles and somehow or
other she let go and I was standing on
this bar and I felt myself beginning to
tip forward and I put my arms in like
this and I fell six feet to the ground
and I broke both my arms at the same
time Wow yeah and so I so I you know I
spent a whole summer I was in Arizona
which is like 120 degrees I don't know
what that is until people
I had a calf and all that you know I was
just miserable
there's a day before the last day of
school anyway I had internalized the
success that's really important
important to do anyway later I want to
raise a superbug I know that we're going
to do the dirty dancing lifts I don't
know however that I have an internalized
phobia of being you know lifted over
someone's head at the height of about
six feet I want to do the left and Ryan
lifts me over his head and I what did i
do right I've never had this happen but
I asked him if a possum fell out of a
tree kind of crash your eyes a lot and
then it was like a full meltdown I mean
I had like a real meltdown yeah you had
to go I think we started to crawl the
bed and watch the lever and haven't
robberies feels like I have to go watch
labyrinth
without crying labyrinth this is so
stupid and then Ryan came here was like
y'all right and then the dresses came in
a really you all right we're going to
use the devil no way Jennifer Chloe it's
a revelation in this grand Norn here if
you'd like to see even more stuff like
that that hit subscribe also free world
but I know what I do in that situation